meet cloud functions a faster way to
build in the cloud you focus on writing
your code and cloud functions make sure
your application runs resilient ly
cost-effectively and at planet scale
allowing you to move faster than ever
before events are happening all the time
in your system like file uploads to
cloud storage changes to database
records requests to http endpoints and
more you write code that runs in
response to those events and cloud
functions runs it and automatically
manages underlying infrastructure for
you and you only pay while your code is
running whether you're building
applications for the enterprise
ecommerce consumers or anyone else cloud
functions makes it easy it connects and
extends your cloud services with code so
that you can treat them as building
blocks move fast and adjust as your
needs change with cloud functions you
can apply artificial intelligence when
new data shows up in your system it only
takes a few lines of code to understand
what's inside your images video or text
bring IOT device data into your
application and analyze it as it arise
use big data analytics and machine
learning in your Google assistant app to
build engaging conversational
experiences for your users or extend
your application using the broad
ecosystem of third-party Services and
api's no matter what you're building
with cloud functions you can innovate
faster focus on what really matters and
build great applications for your users
the possibilities are endless with code
visit cloud google.com slash functions
and go build something amazing today